good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone's having a great day so far hey
jax how you doing i'm doing good so far
so good having a
you know everything's falling into place
sort of morning not behind not moving
forward just on time i would say how are
you
departure and i'm trying to departure
you know
the temperature here in the studio is
really [ __ ] with me because you know
it's so hot outside and then it's
freezing in here so we were like wearing
sweatpants yesterday today um i cannot
stop sweating i'm literally sitting here
with a fan between my legs i'm not okay
um and i just don't appreciate the
imbalance like the climate change in
this studio yeah that's wrong my studio
not to like rub it in or anything i'm
freezing i'm wearing a blanket i have
bryce like he's my personal heating pad
and we're just so cold and chilly and
snowy you're so small and frail and cold
sorry that you're so warm
um not with this handy-dandy amazon fan
blowing between my legs
betwixt my legs are you wearing pants
no i'm wearing shorts and i'm still
sweating like when i tell you how
[ __ ] done i am and how ready i am for
summer to be over like i cannot
cannot stress that enough so over it i
can't wait i mean we're slowly getting
there we're more than halfway through
august august is almost behind us and
that's a cause to celebrate
and i've spent so many weeks this month
in florida that i didn't even have the
chance to realize that it's gotten
chillier in new york like it's been 75
these last two days it's been absolutely
delightful all i need is a good 10
degrees and that is a
temperature i could live with forever
like where is a place
where it's always 65 degrees
besides my bedroom year-round
i don't think you're going to get
year-round stability anywhere that's
where i need to live that's why we have
a winter spring summer
[Music]
all you've got to do is cool
wait by the way speaking of sad songs
i don't know if you saw my instagram
story
i did
smelly pillow my beloved
pillow
that happens to be smelly
died yesterday i don't understand why
how i've had pillows literally since
before i was born that i still use
so the smelly pillow was special because
of this hydro gel flex thing
and it's a pillow cover that really
makes it special and i throw the pillow
cover in the wash like once a week and
something about this particular load it
just like imploded the gel was
everywhere like you're doing it all
wrong
you're not supposed to put that gel
thing in the washer
but it's the pillow cover no it's not
yeah it is no it's not
yes it is okay i'm gonna go look at the
one that's in your bedroom yeah keep
telling me about my smelly pillow i know
ruined your pillow from the jump you
didn't know that no
that you didn't know that pillows come
with pillow covers that you take off and
wash you put your whole pillow in the
washing machine and by the way my whole
pillow in the washing machine it was
totally fine and safe then these last
times became smelly
oh yeah smelly yeah that's not bad i
like the smell like that's what the
whole point of smelly pillow was i was
enjoying the smell okay
but then you told me this magical thing
about a pillow cover i took the pillow
cover off and now i've just been washing
the pillow cover when i washed my sheets
and something about the way it tumbled
it just
didn't make it tumbled too hard it went
too hard it's it was like simone biles
it tumbled too hard did a flip it did a
flip
it was so upsetting like
and last night was the first night i
slept with that smelly pillow
in a really long time and i can't lie
like it was not a good sleep so you
should come back here because i have
your deer pillows twin i know and i know
i could get another one it's not like
this brand of pillow has been
discontinued
um it's just not really the same even
when i was at your house like it was
great but it wasn't the same yeah i'm
sorry that you're going through that sis
it's hard you know grief is it comes in
waves you know there's anger
denial no smelly pillow she can't be
gone she can't
what's the next one
bargaining acceptance acceptance
acceptance is last you have to bargain
i'll give anything for smelly pillow to
be better please take all my other
pillows right i'll literally i'll do
anything to get my smelly pillow back to
me yeah
i'm not at acceptance yet i'm really not
um i just keep waiting for smelly pillow
to like work its way back up the trash
chute
and into my heart will someone just send
her one please the fine people at purple
please send it no i can i can buy my own
pillow it's not even about that it's
about the memories and it's really about
the smell
like i said i'm sorry you're going
through that rip smelly pill
rip smell a pillow
ain't that the truth
um i spent my evening having another
musical interlude not smelly pillow per
se but i was watching elvis music videos
because
harry like really loved elvis when he
was watching with us the movie and so i
was like let's put on some music videos
plus the quality is so shitty that it's
not like you're going to get addicted to
the television right no it's like you
know it's actually not bad for like
focusing or anything it's not going to
drive his attention away it's like one
camera foggy and just good music so it's
actually the perfect thing i think for a
youngin to watch so we were watching uh
elvis tv comeback a bunch of his
performances and then i went down a
spotify rabbit hole of like finding
elvis covers because the elvis songs are
amazing but like listening to the elvis
version
it's just not all of them are like my
particular style but like when the haley
reinhardt covers it all of the times
have changed all of a sudden it's my
vibe so i was really finding the most
premium elvis covers on spotify last
night i posted them to my instagram
story but the journey's not done and
which is the elvis version from crazy
rich asians weddings can't help falling
in love with you no who sings it in what
in crazy retreat oh um
an artist i think her name is kia
something
oh you know simon hawk and phil had the
girl who sang it at crazy rotations at
their wedding wow it was like
that rendition is amazing obviously
casey musgrave's rendition on the album
is really good it's really a song that
you can't [ __ ] up even i i've been
singing it every minute of the day now
hit us come on
wise men say
only
fools rushing
[Music]
but i
can't
help
falling in love
then of course i have to you know make
it my own that was gorgeous yeah it's
like not a difficult song it kind of
sounds like a lullaby yeah i was singing
it all night last night and it's really
like changed my life
man i love that you know i
love when like an older artist
um dead or alive does kind of their
greatest hits albums redone by other
people
um obviously what comes to mind is elton
john's when you know we had so much
goodness especially miley cyrus then we
had uh brooks and dunn doing there's
neon moon with casey musgraves luke
combs i love when like an iconic older
artist does those type of like greatest
hits albums with younger people it's my
favorite thing yeah and i think they did
a good dece i'm sorry a decent amount of
that on the elvis soundtrack for the
album and for the movie they had some
cool moments obviously like hound dog
dojicat is insanely sickening and like
five stars you know frog
yeah you ain't nothing but
no frog uh but there could have been
more and i found oh my god so i sent it
to you and marco i found this cover of
the song from that 68 special i didn't
even know that song if i can dream it
love it new favorite song and it's
covered by
shawn mendes post malone darius rucker
blake shelton and carrie underwood
they're all on it together like stunning
who dreamed this up and why weren't they
on the album for the movie you know post
malone's affinity
for country music is one of my favorite
things and i know you don't have a tick
tock but if you follow him on tick tock
he like records these jam sessions and a
lot of the music he covers is
country like he did brad paisley and he
plays guitar so well and i'm just
waiting for the post malone country
album like i think it
could happen oh he should be on
crossover cmt crossover
is that still a thing i think so i hear
about it sometimes i feel like it's like
the comedy central roast it's like once
every once in a year you never know when
it's gonna happen but it's gonna slap
yeah one of my favorite rabbit holes to
go down on youtube are cmt crossovers
where they have like a pop artist and a
country artist some of my personal
favorites are of course katy perry and
casey musgraves and honorable mention
zach brown band shawn mendes that one's
really good yeah i think and sorry like
the country's now songs like always
sound better
yeah because it's just like about the
tune and the voice kind of like can't
help falling in love with you i think
that's why it's so beautiful my it
sounds even better when i sing it so as
of you know the resident expert on that
song which cover is currently your
favorite
probably haley reinhardt
okay can we talk about hayley reinhart
for a second
she was on american idol she literally
had one of the most unique
voices i remember watching when we were
kids like obsession this gorgeous curly
blonde hair she was just like the girl
of the moment
and
then like nothing came from her
american idol success i don't even
remember if she won or not it doesn't
really matter she had one song released
afterwards what was that song called i
used to love it but what i really used
to love was really rewatching her benny
and the jets performance on american
title she should have been on the
ultimate album snub after snub for haley
no i know and she's just one of those
like really underrated um
singers yeah
i love her people so i put a suggestion
box on my story people were telling me
what their favorite elvis covers are
apparently there's a cover um the wonder
of you from big little lies by the
villagers or something i listened to it
and i can see why other people like it
but it's just like not my style
uh beyonce has a cover of fever that's
really good
and there were a few more but there
really aren't that many and i challenge
hollywood uh and the entertainment
industry to make an album of elvis
covers there is an audience for it and
you guys have especially now yeah of
course with this movie like i think so
many people i was even like watching
juliet porter's story and she was like
is anyone else obsessed with elvis now
and she was listening to his album
and
i just feel like the us kids
we are there's an appetite yes somebody
needs to work with like elvis estate or
like like his life rights whatever it is
just to come out with like a premium ass
album yeah
i love that love that so free idea for
the day
really quickly i wanted to touch on one
thing an update from yesterday's story
when we were talking about ben and jen
and their wedding
it turns out that leah remini was not at
the wedding which
if true which i believe it is tmz
reported it
is
not good no but maybe it was just really
small
okay so
the like
the comment that tmz had gotten from
leah remini's camp
was that she had to hang out with her
daughter because her daughter's going
off to college like i'm sorry that's not
a real reason it's not your best
friend's wedding affleck
right
i'm
i'm shook i'm i was literally just
saying they're one of my favorite female
friendships
and i don't honestly like i
i don't know what i do like that would
really be
huge i think that they're fine i really
do
i'm not worried okay i don't think it
was like super hollywood-y
and also i need to update everyone
because i i guess yesterday i called
jennifer garner jessica garner
common misconception yeah um
her name is jennifer oops my bad
my bad oops that one's on me oh
personal update i am like under 5 000
followers away from 200 000 followers on
tick tock which if you know how
desperate i am um that's huge for me so
if everyone could just take a moment if
your name is jessica or jennifer or kate
or any any kind of version of kate
catherine kathleen uh follow me on tick
tock please maybe you want to follow me
on tik tok at jackie o because you never
know when she's coming back
yeah for sure but you can't even get
into your account so like i don't want
to i know but when that is energy when i
do you don't want to miss what i've got
brewing
do you know what like your debut content
is going to be not at all we'll have to
come up with something good yeah
maybe it'll be
this clip
from the podcast oh my god i could start
posting the podcast clips to mine
or you could just start posting like
your own no but they're just as much
mine as they are yours no for sure like
we can make more so like we're not like
posting triple content you know yeah we
can make more what do you guys like that
[Music]
i don't know i'll have to talk to ac and
see what she wants the account is hers
100 you should get your account changed
too at american campaign well the bio is
counselor snitch fan account and that's
never going to change
also we have a tv recap today because
jackie and i both watched the first
episode of house of dragons which is the
game of thrones prequel that premiered
on hbo to a whopping 10 million viewers
yeah we're going to talk about
the
reviews and then we're going to review
it ourselves that's in the fifth and
final oh i didn't know what the reviews
were
no not necessarily reviews but just some
stats statistics the fifth and final
into the tv recap segment which we
haven't done in so long so and i'm
bringing back full force this week i
can't wait for beverly hills i'm gonna
give you a recap like you've never
[ __ ] seen before wow i can't wait but
i think without further ado we should
jump right into the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
clinique meet clinique's first
foundation designed to be the last step
in your skincare routine the even better
clinical serum foundation is formulated
with three serum technologies that
visibly reduce dark spots brighten and
hydrate skin so i love a good foundation
much as an ex girl and i'm really
particular about foundation and i've
been speaking a lot about how much i
like the clinique one and what i really
like about it obviously is like the look
the way it like looks and feels but the
fact that it's built with skin care
inside of it so you know that it's not
going to be clogging your pores or
making any breakouts you have worse like
it's working for you while making you
look beautiful stunning and smart and i
think that that's just fabulous and in
as little as eight weeks your skin can
appear even more toned radiant and
smoother even your even after your
makeup is removed it's not really a
foundation like it doesn't do it just ex
justice because it's a clinical
foundation it has three serums inside of
it
um and you can complete your regimen by
visibly correcting hydrating and
smoothing the look of skin after
everywhere their bottles are recyclable
so you can remove the cap and the pump
and then rinse the bottle which is glass
and then place it in a recycling bin um
they have a they promise a 24 hour color
true wear it's oil free waterproof
sweat-proof and humidity resistant um it
doesn't cake it does increase it's a
fabulous foundation clinique is a brand
you can truly trust for makeup and for
skin care so this product is just all in
one don't call it makeup it is skincare
in your shade they offer over 42 shades
which is a huge range and you can find
your shade today at clinique.com
today's episode is also brought to you
by suma
zuma zuma let me be osuma sumatumatum
yeah that's right [ __ ]
today's episode is brought to you by
thuma because your bedroom deserves a
refresh and now it is a perfect time to
elevate the most important room in your
home
it's made for how you live the bed by
thuba is backed with a lifetime warranty
it ships right to your door in three
easy to maneuver boxes and it takes
about five minutes to assemble with no
tools required if you've ever set up a
bed you know that about five minutes and
no tools required is simply unheard of
but not from thuma
comes in a bunch of different colors
their bed is obviously easy to set up
it's also just like really gorgeous
minimal it's the vibe of the moment you
know they also have other bedroom
essentials um like the mattress the
nightstand and the side table and they
all perfectly complement the bed
their practice is an intentional less is
more design philosophy for the bedroom
that means clean lines subtle curves and
lifestyle enhancing details you can
create that feeling of checking into
your favorite boutique hotel suite but
at home with the bed by thuma and now go
to thuma dot co slash toast to receive a
25 credit towards your purchase of the
bed plus free shipping in the
continental us go to thuma dot co thuma
dot co slash toast that's t h u m a dot
c o slash toast for 25 dollar credit
love it okay our first story some
podcast news
meghan markle's first podcast has
premiered on spotify
meghan markle has a new podcast as part
of their you know deal from three years
ago 100 years ago uh where they only put
out one episode but now her first show
is here it's called archetypes and she
is deconstructing the history of
societal stereotypes about women in her
first show for spotify which premiere
today the first episode of archetypes
features serena williams who recently
announced her plans to retire from pro
tennis that's a good get that's a good
guess she's talking with megan about the
double standard women face when they are
labeled ambitious and dr laura cray a
professor at uc berkeley and an expert
on gender in the workplace next week's
episode will feature a conversation with
mariah carey so this week's episode is
all about you know and uh the word
ambition and how for women it's like the
worst thing to be called and she
learned that uh you know when she met
and married her husband
and everyone was criticizing her quote
unquote ambition
got it got it okay um so it is a podcast
hosted by her yes
okay because that was confusing also i
feel like there was a lot of like hoopla
around them having a podcast when it was
announced and now it's been three whole
years to get one episode out and i can't
like i do imagine that some of the
fanfare has passed
yeah also i mean
they signed their deal back in 2020 then
they released one holiday episode and
then there was nothing and it wasn't
until like the new york post
kind of like exposed them because there
was a
what was it a job description for like
someone to like do the show and it's
like where is the there are no episodes
there is no show and i guess that must
have like lit a fire under someone's
butt to be like this is embarrassing and
what did we pay them millions of dollars
for if they're not for one episode it
was so weird and you know what when it
comes to this episode you guys know how
i feel about serena williams would take
a bullet um and i'm
i believe in the message i just don't
know and by the way this is a personal
choice like choice like if i'm going to
a podcast like it's not for gender
studies
but some other people might like want to
get their you know
empowerment from podcasts but for me
like i'm looking at podcasts for
entertainment for pop culture for comedy
um so like this is not my particular
genre but i do imagine there are people
who enjoy this but that's just to say
even though i love serena williams like
i will not be listening to this yeah
no honestly like it sounds kind of
miserable
you know it just sounds like so serious
and like
and like i get that's what some people
like listen to podcasts for but not me
yeah the first episode is called the
misconception of ambition
i just i'm really trying like hard not
to be negative i'm sorry but like when
you're meghan markle and like you
have like all the contexts all the
access and like you're making us listen
to a professor from uc berkeley about
like
miserable
no like one thing about me and this is
absolutely no hate to the academic
community but like if there is a doctor
or a professor on a podcast like i will
be skipping it
yeah like i don't want to hear from a
psychologist it's doctor phil or doc
100 unless you're a tv doctor drew
what's the one from six hundred pound
life
oh doctor nazardon i mean i would listen
to a 24 hour live stream of dr nizardin
say maybe she could get him on next
so yes you're right unless you're a
doctor who's appeared on tv multiple
times then i'm not interested
but
like i'm just not into like
psychologists or professors or you know
phds like that's but that's my opinion
yeah you might like this episode i'm
just saying that's not what i
particularly search for in podcasts or
like there are categories of like
education where like people you know
talk to exclusively
doctors psychologists or doctors
psychologists have podcasts and like
huge audiences i love that for them but
like when it's like something in the pop
culture realm like this is a celebrity
podcast we're having serena williams
yeah you know what
it's like a spotify original with like
premium guests it sounds like she's
gonna be competing with alex cooper for
guests totally like alex cooper just
had demi lovato like they're on the same
level and like the week before i think
she had a doctor
i rest my case yeah no so it's just like
spotify turning out like the same
content like interview shows hosted by
women about women
right about womanhood about yeah female
tings femininity and about the
misconception of ambition and this is
just kind of like low-key like
unoriginal i'm trying so hard not to be
a hater but i support podcasting in all
forms and i welcome i really do i
welcome someone as famous as elite as
royal as meghan markle to our trenches
you know i do of female podcasters but i
just like loki expecting more after
three years like we're just oh so it's
just an interview show like everyone
else like it's armchair expert it's
called her daddy it's like a regular
podcast yeah i will say the artwork is
stunning
oh stunning gorgeous glamorous
black and white stripped down photo of
megan
oh and by the way that font
that she's using is daily mail i'm sorry
this is the daily mail article oh i
thought it was like a tape i thought it
was a take on tabloid culture no that
would be cool but no this is the font
it's very like times new archetypes yeah
i love the fancy i love the branding and
i like the beat
i like the beat and i welcome i really
do i welcome another female podcaster
who overall rising tides raise all ships
i'm just looking at this through a
critical lens um and i'm like oh after
three years of like so much hoopla
that's
that's it
yeah i agree and it's like one of those
pockets has like a million producers you
know it's still like it pockets a
conversation sit down and chat yeah what
what the [ __ ] is up with bruno why is he
barking on our podcast because he wants
his own podcast now he's been waiting he
keeps coming to me he's like mom please
ready brew types and i'm like bro you're
too young it's too much pressure like
just enjoy life in your childhood and he
hears just like talking about how we
support other podcasters and he's like
what about me i'm like shut up do we
have any details of their spotify deal
and is it them or just megan
i thought it was them and this is just
like my memory but could be totally
wrong i was thinking 20 million
for how many
episodes
i have no idea
let me google that
harry megan
and where's his podcast
so are they doing separate shows or
maybe like next week it's like a harry
hosted episode with like him and oprah
25 million dollars
for what like 10
years there was a time where they were
just like snatching up those deals
netflix spotify disney plus yeah
i don't know how how long that was for
i'm it's not really here
i would be so shook if it's 25 million
for just like one
season of this podcast for megan because
we don't really know
you know are people gonna i mean they
are gonna listen because people like
megan is that famous and it seems like
her tier of guests is gonna be beyond
elite yeah so maybe you won't tune in to
every episode but you'll tune in for the
guests that you like i think that's how
a lot of people look at podcasts yeah
also like i think she is you know
opening up there was a headline like she
i hadn't listened i haven't listened to
her episode yet so also i i do you know
take whatever i'm saying with a grain of
salt if i'm critical or praising it i
haven't listened but she did like share
uh anecdote about a trip that they went
on like i think it was a royal trip they
were in south africa and
the heater in uh archie's nursery caught
on fire i don't think he was in the
nursery but then they had to like go out
and do um
press and i think it was just she was
sharing so i think people might tune in
if she's he'll share yeah well if she's
gonna spill the tea
then that's a podcast that is a podcast
that's a podcast like interviewing your
famous friends like honestly that's not
going to cut it no with like questions
that are you know
about over by five different people and
you know
no just yeah just like kind of
regurgitating like common like we all
know women are treated differently like
if you're not saying anything different
like talking about it isn't going to
change it but we know already and nobody
knows better than serena williams yeah
yeah so if she's not adding anything new
to like conversations we already know
like oh what's next uh
the ocean is filled with plastic like we
know
like we gotta do do you lean on podcasts
to tell you something new or original or
yeah
oh yeah that's what the space has become
you know i guess you could do whatever
you want on this here mike sure
but
that's what the people like if you know
new thoughts and feelings yeah thoughts
and tings that's a new podcast we should
have on tna she should recap real
housewives like do something crazy
yeah or like give us an insight like
what is it like like you got what you
wanted like you guys got out do you feel
free what do you do on the weekends like
give me something yeah
who are you friends with like you went
to dinner with david foster what was
that like
maybe he'll be on the pod
right would love love it in depth it
will be really interesting to see which
of her famous friends come on because i
do feel like some of the people that she
was friends with she's not friends with
anymore some of the people you think she
would be friends with now that she's out
she's not friends with so i want to know
who her friends are
let's guess okay i feel like she'll have
priyanka chopra on well they were such
good friends but for some reason
i thought they weren't friends anymore
i don't know why i feel like there was
something
something that one of them should have
been at that they weren't at
maybe it was megan was obviously megan
wasn't at her wedding right
but she was at megan yeah
so we'll see so we'll see
um what is her vibe with the kardashians
i was gonna say like you would think she
could be friends with kim but chris
chris i could see if she wanted to have
like a mogul on i think that would be an
interesting episode everyone's always
like let's get chloe and kim on the
podcast and that's all great what about
chris
yeah yeah that's an episode we could
learn something these are some good
ideas
and by the way i i can be bought like if
you want some of my ideas spotify hit me
up
yeah
okay
we'll keep you posted anyways yeah
exciting podcasting needs to stop off
the day and i always love that
rising tides raise all ships and it's
not fair to really have like uh
we can't
have any judgments until we see what she
does and we listen to an episode but
just like the vibe that was described to
me just seemed kind of like me yeah i'm
gonna try and listen today if i can make
any time for that yeah i'll listen but
i'm not gonna listen to the doctor part
i'm sorry like i have to set some
boundaries for myself i'll listen to
serena williams but
and that's not to say i don't respect
doctors or professors
yeah i don't think i say but i don't i
don't think i'm going to use a doctor
oh i couldn't remember so i just kept
saying both
no she's a doctor sorry sorry okay
okay well you could be a doctor and a
professor
love that for her
are you ready for our next story
yes it's the name on everybody's lips
the brand new real housewives of new
york star has been revealed
one of the new members of the cast of
the revamped rahone so this is not
legacy this is with the new girls is
texan fashion
influencer lizzie savetsky page six has
learned the fort worth texas native has
some 200 000 followers on instagram
where she posts frequently about
accessories and her jewish faith she's
also a mother of three and married to
plastic surgeon dr ira savetsky the
social media star recently spoke
publicly about her struggle with alcohol
which of course has been something of a
recurring theme on the show in the case
of various other cast members so lizzie
savetsky she actually was she used to
live in dallas she was supposed to be on
the new season of real housewives of
dallas but then that got canned her and
her family recently moved to new york
and from what we understand they are
kind of centering the new season
young roni around her
and what i've heard that i think is
really cool is like she's super by the
way and i just love that the show is
being centered around someone jewish
like
it's new york like can we have one thing
um and what i've heard from pretty like
legit sources is that she is totally
like staying totally observant she
observes shabbat which means she doesn't
drive or work or use her phone or
anything um they're working around like
the holidays and shabbat for her like
when they go on cast trips like they're
not gonna make her drive or like with
the microphone they're gonna use a boom
like they're working around her
observant
tease and i think that's cool that is
really cool i think you told me that but
it's just really now registering
especially with like cash trips and not
using a microphone that's right cool uh
she must have like tested really well
when they filmed her in dallas and then
when they heard she was moving to new
york and they're also looking for a
young cast they're looking for a cast
with the social media following it's and
she has like a whole family and i think
she her husband you know they're very
they're always posting content together
we both follow her and her contents fire
flames her eyes are so cute i think
she's going to make a really good
housewife and she is a housewife she is
a mom she's an influencer and she's like
she's all the things that they said that
they wanted and now it's happening right
there are some other names that were
swirling about who might also there was
one other girl in this page six article
she's an executive at vera wing named
priya
shukla she's in the mix for a role on
the show but she hasn't signed on as a
full-time member of the cast yet if they
have started filming it must have been
so recently because i think lizzie moved
to new york two weeks ago right well
that's kind of been the only thing that
like housewives fans are like upset
about they're like well she's not even
from new york who cares i hate when
people are like you're a transplant but
like is lizzy from texas no
no she she moved to texas during the
pandemic yeah i was following her so i
don't know where she lived before that
she lived in new york
okay i do believe she lived in new york
so but i'm just saying like gatekeeping
how many years someone lives in new york
like that's extremely elitist
but also that i hate when people do that
so on new york new york is a melting pot
it's right first like
historically it's been the first place
where everyone from the world comes if
they're coming to the country like
that's new york it's everyone
no like this new york transplant thing
like it's they literally sound like they
build a wall like calm down
like it's like people from new york are
so [ __ ] annoying about that like
well
you lived in
london for one year you're not a new
yorker yeah shut up literally shut the
[ __ ] up it also goes the other way for
people who like trying to keep new york
but it's like you're from upstate luanne
sonja you know like these people aren't
even from new york and they act like
anyone who isn't from new york is no
one's from new york technically you know
what i mean everyone came right we're
all from our mother's wombs that's true
i just i hate that [ __ ] like that's
become like such a thing like you're not
a new yorker f no like if i l you live
here you're a new yorker like i hate
people that gate keep calling p
themselves a new yorker like you could
only call yourself a new yorker if you
did that but you know what up i also
hate i hate when like people move out of
new york
and like years later are like well i'm a
new yorker i'm like
i agree
i think like still i can say i'm i am a
new yorker but i that will expire and i
need to figure out when that is
i completely agree because like if
you're moving like you are where you
live so sorry if you live in texas
you're a texan i don't care if you were
born in lenox hill hospital you're not
in new york like you are where you live
i agree people like take that as a
personality trait wherever they move
yeah they're like once you're gone like
you're gone it's so gina kirschenfeiter
it's it's the new yorker in me i know
don't ever let me be that person
never but i am such a
you're really not and like you're
like your time is almost up like dead
ass no but i can but i guess like the
way that i talk i'm very new york my
attitude is very new york no time no
patience no [ __ ] no [ __ ] box no
[ __ ] books but is that even new
yorkers these days anymore no they're
all just like miserable cretans
blase like like
yeah i don't know what like the current
contemporary vibe of a new yorker is
i think it's going through change and
weirdly i think these new real
housewives shows will probably influence
how the world sees new yorkers
well this is what's interesting i feel
like for a long time people have been
saying like housewives like needs like a
facelift like they need to skew younger
they need to like have you know
more
instagrammy people and this is exactly
what it is so we'll see if it works i'm
really excited so far so good like
i have full hope
yeah i think it's a good call
and you're right if she was able to be
casted on both franchises like she
obviously has something you know
she's i mean i've actually met her sorry
she's like so nice so pretty so
hilarious very outgoing should make a
great housewife and i do think the
alcohol thing is interesting i don't
know if that's the best environment for
someone who's like struggling with
alcohol currently but it will make for
interesting conversations on the show i
saw she posted about it on her instagram
recently i think she's sober been sober
for a number of years like very strong
in her sobriety
okay yeah okay our next story some more
bravo news nene leakes has dropped her
discrimination lawsuit against bravo and
andy cohen nene leaks his job for
discrimination lawsuit against andy
cohen bravo the network's parent company
nbc universal and the production company
true entertainment for now at least
according to court documents obtained by
page six the real housewives of atlanta
alum filed on friday to dismiss the case
without prejudice meaning she
has the ability to reopen it at a later
time
reps for nene declined page six's
request for comment on her future
strategy in the meantime the parties
involved in the case agreed to not seek
recovery of costs or attorney's fees per
the documents the case's conclusion
comes two months after page six reported
in june that nene had been in
negotiations with bravo andy and nbc
universal to possibly settle their case
outside of court
well if you're dropping your lawsuit i
guess that means it's not going well
right like she wasn't going to win yeah
or
could they now cut your life settle
outside of court
i don't know um this was like such a sad
way for like the end of nene's time on
housewives because she really was like
a founding father of housewives culture
um
and to be honest i really have not kept
up with this at all i just i do follow
nene on twitter so it's pretty much all
she talks about on twitter so that's how
i knew it was still going on um and i'm
really curious what andy's take on this
is because i honestly don't believe andy
is
i think he's far from innocent like in
general like i don't i don't think the
andy we see is like the andy who he
actually is and i'm sure there's lots of
nefarious business that goes on behind
the scenes but i do know that like him
and nene like really loved each other
and like really respected each other and
so much of her lawsuit is
about andy yeah um
and so that's sad to see the dissolution
of a friendship very sad i wonder if
he'll comment on it or speak i guess now
that it's dropped why would he do that
if he hasn't said anything thus far and
like it was a big story when it happened
it was like filed
and then like there was no follow-ups
like it's been a really long time so
things just like fizzled out so andy if
he hasn't said anything probably won't
yeah and i guess i mean
i feel like there was always you know
and throughout the years like it would
spin a you know a
revolving door of whether nene is on
this show or that show or her own show
where she could come back and i guess
once you like sue everyone involved
there's no coming back
it's done it's done
and that sucks
yeah
because one thing about any even though
in her final season's like my god did
she piss me off like she
i'm sorry like she was happy it's an
icon
she
nobody is funnier nobody makes better tv
she did lose her mind a little bit
towards the end i think she had way too
much pride
um that like conflicted with her
being a good housewife yeah
but she will be missed and
i wonder what happened yeah okay i'm
like kind of like nosy of course
just curious yeah
our next story is a tick tock video that
has is brought to you by pique is that
it yeah yeah
did you know that moisturizers don't
actually hydrate your skin they just
seal the outer layer of your skin to
prevent your internal internal moisture
from leaking out so if you don't already
have enough hydration inside of you
topical creams are not going to help you
that much but that's why peaks bt
foundation is the first skin care that
you can drink it enhances and boosts
internal moisture production and
preservation for results in less than 30
days so we've been drinking the peak uh
beauty electrolyte for almost a week and
i have to say the concept of like
starting with skin care from the inside
makes so much sense because if you're
not drinking enough water and you're not
like you know fueling your body with
good things like it'll show on the
outside um and i love this concept of
like makeup for your insides i think
it's a great place to get started if
you're having trouble with your skin
i definitely felt a huge boost in
hydration like a like a deeper hydration
not just like a hydration that sits on
the surface i felt like there was more
of a glow to my skin people have been
commenting on it um
and more like full like plump like less
raisin vibes you know
so
the ceramides visibly reduce fine lines
and increase your skin elasticity the
hyaluronic acid increases the skin
moisture content and the electrolytes
electrolytes provide deep cellular
hydration so peak is offering a limited
time offer just for our listeners get 15
off plus free shipping for life when you
subscribe at peak life dot com slash
toast pika spelled p i q u e l i f e dot
com slash toast for 15 off and free
shipping
for life thank you so much for that
it's pleasure
doing business with y'all
now
you're selling bizarre it sounds our
next story is a tick tock video that is
exposing how grocery stores manipulate
you into spending more money using
psychological tricks
and
this is i found this to be so
interesting so it's a tick tock user who
is showing you how every part of the
grocery store is designed to make you
spend more money starting with what you
see first the way that you go around the
store so first you see flowers to put
you in a good mood
then you see uh
the healthy foods which make customers
splurge on less healthy and more
expensive items later think about how
you go through a grocery store you
always walk in you see the flowers and
then you go towards the produce right
they also increase their cart size to
make you
think you can add more items to your
cart
they play like music to put you in a
good mood and keep you shopping longer
they have prepared foods at the end as a
reward
they use scent marketing like prefer
them pies in the bakery
to lure you in
and this one tick tock user the recount
is exposing all the different ways and
not to fall for it next time i go to a
grocery store it's also like the way
that they do the aisles also the way on
the shelves like
whatever's at eye level is the most
expensive and whatever is higher and or
lower are the products that are cheaper
because they want you to just like grab
the more expensive one how every single
element of a grocery store is just like
a psychological trick so i've heard
about this trickery um done in casinos
um you know there's no windows so you
don't really know how much time has
passed they pump extra oxygen in the air
to keep you awake longer there's so many
different things there's no clocks
anywhere good luck finding out what time
it is um and all those things make sense
to me i know there's a lot of things um
at costco
that are psychological warfare as well
you know the rotisserie chicken is one
of their best sellers and it's a losing
it's a
product that loses money consistently
for costco but they place it all the way
in the back after this maze so that you
have to walk through their entire store
pick up a couple things in order to get
that rotisserie chicken that they're
losing money on but they're
making money on everything you purchased
in route to the rotisserie chicken
however uh the person i think who made
this tick tock is like
being like this is a little bit of a
stretch they put flowers at the front to
make you smell good yeah like this is a
little stupid it makes so much sense
every grocery store has the same thing
also the way that you walk around the
store it's counterclockwise something
about that like is designed to
make you spend more money if you're
moving in the same direction that you
drive in but also think about it why is
every single grocery store chain like
they all do these practices
never once no what you said about the
most expensive items being eye level
like that makes sense yeah they also she
said prepare food at the end for a
little treat that is dumb that's just
what i disagree
no i think like this person on tick tock
tried to make like you know make us
think and some of the [ __ ] they said is
dumb
next time i go to the grocery store i'm
going clockwise
oh you'll show and see if i am more
economical
it's so true because you like you you
walk past the produce first and like you
just kind of like ignore everything but
then you're halfway through the story
and you're like [ __ ] i didn't get enough
so then you start putting in like all
these unhealthy things
i guess that's really not how i grocery
shop but maybe i'm just immune to
psychological warfare like i have a list
and what i need i get yeah
like
i don't go you grocery shopping for
leisure like i'm in and out i gotta get
you i gotta feed my family because it's
not you know a production in the city
but for the rest of the world myself
included now that i'm uh not even not a
new yorker
it is and they're using psychological
warfare so just keep this in mind i mean
for the most a lot of the time i'm just
like
okay good for you you figured it out
this your business and you're you know
making business um but i'm just gonna
keep these things in mind from that one
what do you think about casinos like do
you think that's taking advantage of
people
no
no and especially because the things
that they do in casinos to make you like
stay longer not realize how much time
has passed i actually like like if i was
in a casino that was like broad daylight
yeah no it's like the vibe giving you
free drinks and there's no clocks like
okay
right right like oh no you're taking my
clocks away but i'm getting a free
tequila soda i'll live yeah
yeah i mean
it's obviously everything like most
things there's a scale you know for me
i'm just in and out i i don't even enjoy
gambling and i think the free drinks
that they give you are nasty disgusting
uh
so i mean i'm not gonna want to stick
around for that long clocks are no
clocks windows or no windows but other
people have different predilections
but you know what i think is interesting
is like the psychological warfare behind
costco like there's so i actually follow
a guy or maybe not follow but he comes
up all the time for me he delves into
like how costco stays afloat when
they've been selling you know their best
seller is their hot dog and it's never
not been 99 cents and they it never
won't be 99 cents yeah but it's like
that's and so how could a company whose
best seller is losing their money how
can that make any sense and i don't
think they really ever change the price
of their food like food products like
not like on shelves but at like the
little restaurant um and that's because
that's what keeps people coming in
that's what keeps people paying the 90 a
year whatever it is for their membership
so even though they're losing money on
that overall it's bringing people in the
store using a membership and then also
getting them to just peruse
the other aisles buying stuff that they
probably don't need that makes money for
costco
damn son makes you think you need a
doctorate for these grocery stores
hut to navigate these waters we need a
grocery store doctor
uh like psychological doctor doctor of
science psychology on the show to
explain these tactics and how we can
combat them in our everyday lives and
how to spot them that's the hard part
you don't even know you're being
warfared and which
chains are the most nefarious and which
just
are putting out the food
you know yeah like just doing what we
asked yeah
makes you think and
yeah no because it also makes you think
a lot of people order their groceries
online now oh various services and
you're becoming immune to the warfare
right but they can put that warfare in
the app putting the you know the certain
products oh and they definitely do
search something and you can't find it
but like you know that store carries it
it's like they don't want you to buy it
warfare warfare
now it's time for our fifth and final
story that will lead into our tv recap
wait where's my story i sent you a story
oh my god you did i forgot and we're
talking about this is dumb [ __ ]
grocery [ __ ] oh my god you did i
forgot
pull it up totally
i've requested a story late last night
oh my god i've been waiting like oh my
god it's my next yay it's my next
gwyneth paltrow will make a guest
appearance on shark tank alongside door
dash ceo tony zoo gwyneth paltrow is set
to make her first time appearance on
shark tank ins as a guest
in season 14.
the doordash ceo will also might make
his first appearance this season
the actress founded the lifestyle brand
known as goop she became ceo of the
company in 2016 alongside its book
imprints skincare and fragrances lines
and live events goops has two netflix
shows and now she will join the long
time sharks and shirt in search of their
next big thing shark tank season 14
premieres on friday september 23rd
i just love this first of all i love the
guest shark
industry you know like who they choose i
find so interesting especially when it's
like celebrities and honestly like kind
of like dropped the ball since bethany
and to be honest there was like so much
hoopla for bethany and i didn't think
she was like that great i thought she
was like kind of like a bully like yeah
she's also she's not an ensemble kind of
gal she's a one-woman show and so like
yeah it was just
she didn't blend she didn't mesh into
the cast it was like the sharks invested
the bethany show yeah no you're so right
that's exactly what it was
um
and honestly i felt as though she was
out of her depth honestly yeah me too
and it's like the products had to be so
tailored for like the skinny girl brand
and it was just she's not uh as far as
we know like a very versatile investor
she has a very specific niche
and you know not everyone wants a little
on the go wax kit for your mustache a
hundred percent um
however i think gwyneth paltrow is an
amazing choice one because like gwyneth
is just like that [ __ ] like wherever
she goes she fits in you know whether
she's singing on glee or being the mom
and politician like she's a chameleon
she can really like be the best funniest
version of herself for the environment
that she's in yes and i also think her
area of expertise which is wellness is
such a huge category that it's broad
that so many different companies can
come and they can pick from a lot of
different companies to tailor to her
episode and i also just especially with
her show i never even really watched it
but it's just i did clips and episodes
like she's so open-minded so i yeah i
feel like there's nothing that she won't
hear she's so like inclusive and just
like wants to learn and i feel like she
could i could see her sitting for a
pitch about anything and being really
into it genuinely into it and i love
like just like on song land shark tank
like you really get a sense of the
person's acumen when it comes to
whatever their field is so we get to see
like who's actually a good songwriter
and a performer on the young man totally
who's actually a sound business mind on
shark tank and i think gwyneth is that
mind and i look forward to being proven
right yeah i think people are going to
be really surprised by what they see
like i think she's i mean goop is worth
over a billion dollars people mocked her
endlessly for it over the years she
persevered it's now like the wellness
company
she's just everything of the sort and i
think like
whatever your conception of gwyneth
paltrow is like this will change it like
i think you're gonna leave the episode
having like an enormous amount of
respect for her her brain i think you're
gonna have like
an enormous amount of respect for the
company that she's built and then
personal
personality wise like she's so funny
she's so beautiful like i think
everywhere she goes people are just like
enamored with her glow
yeah magnetic yes yeah i'm really
excited and also i do feel like i
am such a big shark tank fan but i
haven't watched in years me neither i
don't know why i feel like the ball has
been dropped a little bit some of their
guest sharks haven't done it for me
or just you know the marketing i think i
even record every episode it never even
occurred to me to watch over the last
two years like now i'm
back in the game no i completely tank we
were we were talking about shark tank on
the show like every single day two years
ago and i think like their coveted
episodes when they were all like spread
out it was just like every business was
like as a sanitizer for your phone like
it was like a lot of cobid and i think
people don't want to turn on tv and be
reminded of the worst time of their
[ __ ] life and every business is like
okay but how is it impacted how is this
a business
right yes
yeah yes so i love this selection i
cannot wait to see what googlenet does
and i will be tuning in
same same same
now are you ready for our fifth and
final story that will lead into our tv
recap
i am i'm really excited house of the
dragon series premiere crashes the hbo
max application on amazon devices
10 million viewers tuned in to the house
of dragon premiere on sunday night and
a ton of amazon devices went down and
crashed the hbo max site due to the
popularity and all the fanfare for the
new show
so i saw this morning that
over 10 million people tuned in
and you know what like i wasn't even
really like looking
this wasn't on my radar at all and i
wasn't like waiting for the drop and
then it came out i was like oh i'd love
to do the recaps on the toast let me
watch it me and ben watched it last
night
and it brought me right back to that
moment like watching a show where i'm
incredibly confused everything is really
dark i have to turn my lights off like
that energy just brought me back to such
a great fun time in my life yeah and i
loved it no i loved it i like you like
when i knew that there was a prequel
coming out i just assumed like it would
never be here and now that it's here i'm
like oh i should watch it was such a
great time to like be a part of
something and obviously 10 million other
people felt the same thing and as i was
watching the first episode yes i was
really confused in some of the like
small council scenes i'm like what are
they talking about but then you have to
remember how confused you were season
one episode one of game of thrones and
like it doesn't matter that you were
confused
you'll figure it out along the way so i
was just along for the ride i thought
the show was so good it's
like
doing no disgrace to the legacy of game
of thrones
it's
it's
it's just what we need honestly
well let's recap the episode um because
i have a lot of questions for you
because you're like the resident game of
thrones encyclopedia and like when i
don't understand something like i need
you to excite it to me and it is brought
to you by
air doctor okay so my air doctor is
sitting right over there when i was
staying at your house i had one in my
bedroom which i really appreciated
because
air doctor is it so clean air breathing
in clean air it is the fastest and
easiest way to have a positive impact on
your health and it's so important to
improve the quality of your indoor air
with a high quality air purifier and
then all you have to do is breathe so
whether you have allergies or asthma
there are certain things you can do to
ensure that your indoor air quality is
getting better and that it's healthy for
you
that's why you've got to check out air
doctor you are breathing over 20 000
times a day and the air doctor is going
to fill out any dangerous contaminants
and allergens so that your lungs don't
have to do that they use an ultra hepa
filter that's been independently tested
to remove 99.9
of tested bacteria and viruses so
allergens can vary in size but the
average pollen size is about 25 microns
and the air doctor captures particles as
small as .003 microns in that size which
is 100 times smaller than even the hepa
standard so what i really like about air
doctors obviously all the fancy things
it does to get the toxins the allergens
the bacteria out of your air and you'll
feel a visible difference in how you're
breathing but also there are some
purifiers that are just [ __ ] ugly
like really but ugly like who wants that
in their house i'm looking at it right
now air doctors sleek sometimes i forget
it's here it's quiet it doesn't make
itself known it blends in i have it in
white it's just like it's really truly
stunning um and it's aesthetically
pleasing which is nice because if you're
trying to cultivate a nice vibe in your
bedroom you don't want like a big ugly
thing
um the classic air doctor 3000 purifier
which is what we have is powerful enough
to circulate the air in a 630 plus
square foot room four times an hour
so within a few days of getting the air
doctor you will notice a huge difference
for me i noticed a difference in
congestion for ben i noticed a huge
decrease in his coughing and throat
clearing and his itchy nose and if these
are things you struggle with especially
seasonally i would recommend checking
out air doctor they come with a no
questions asked 30 day money back
guarantee so that so if you don't love
it just send it back for a refund minus
the shipping head to
airdoctorpro.com and use the promo code
toast and depending on the model you'll
receive up to 30 off 35 off excuse me so
that's up to 35 percent off but only if
you go to a i r d o c t r o r p r o dot
com use promo code
toast.airdoctorpro.com
promo code toast all right so here was
my first initial question for the game
of thrones house of dragons
recap
um i just felt like i wasn't sure who we
were supposed to like and like be
rooting for
and i will refer to everyone as how they
are related to the king because i don't
remember any names but i think his name
is damon the brother yeah are we
supposed to be rooting for him because
like i kind of was but he was also
giving like villainous vibes yeah i
think it's meant to be a little
ambiguous but no i i feel like he is one
of those mad targaryens with an easy
streak because that roundup of the
kingsguard like
that wasn't quite just yeah but but it
was like
thieves and rape
did they have a trial or was he going
through the town just calling people
thieves rapists and murderers oh that's
a good question never occurred to me
yeah okay my other question was like did
you get any sexy vibes between
new air and her uncle damon yes and
it would behoove everyone if they got
together and produced an heir
uh
who would sit on the throne and you know
they do love a little uncle niece lovin
they do and like not to be disgusting
but like i ship i was like yes and he's
not just i think he's disgusting
oh i think he's kind of hot and i was
like into his vibe but i i like knew
that that was wrong do you know what i
mean yeah maybe i think a lot of only
when his hair was flat ironed by the way
like when he had curly hair i was like
ew
but at the funeral his hair was like
slick looked like he had a keratin
treatment i was like yeah
he was a little too evil for my liking
and like in with all the
girls and the air for a day it was just
twisted okay air for a day was [ __ ] up
but he wasn't wrong what he said to the
king he's like you're weak like everyone
in there just wants something from you
you're the hand of your your king is
like sending his daughter in to [ __ ] you
a minute after your wife dies the guy at
the end of the table just wants his wife
to be queen like everybody wants
something from you you're too dumb to
see it yes and and no like they all want
a little something from him but like no
one really there is like evil i think
everyone is sending his daughter in
everyone's trying to further themselves
but i think that damon like is the only
one who if he actually had any power
would really make the lives of the
people miserable
i'm not i'm holding judgment i'm into
damon i think there's a little charisma
there also obviously that girly daughter
of the king who's best friends with this
the heir
went in [ __ ] him she's pregnant and
now it's like well he named the
successor but he has an error
on the way
oh you think they already [ __ ] 100 i
think they were just laying the
groundwork
okay well either way that's gonna happen
yeah for sure
okay the scene
you know where they cut the baby yeah
that was really like
extremely difficult to watch and like i
really felt like we didn't need to see
it yeah so a lot of people a few people
they told me trigger warning for that
scene like for mamas and then i saw like
a post article like there's a scene so
then i figured like when you know it's
time for the birth something bad is
gonna happen i kind of closed my eyes so
i didn't really see anything like too
gory but i understood what was happening
you know he murdered his wife
uh there and like does that make sense
like i didn't know but then it was like
they wouldn't be in this position if it
wasn't for him being obsessed with
having a son and like not even thinking
once like oh maybe my lovely daughter
who loves combat and is actually really
smart like maybe she would make a good
king so like they were only in that
position because he was [ __ ] annoying
but like
if it was a normal situation like i
guess that was common back then like you
sacrificed one for the other yeah but
then the baby didn't even make it oh
that was terrible the little baby in the
funeral terrible but it's also so crazy
i think about this all the time how like
modern medicine you know what she was
having was a c-section
performed all the time now babies are in
breach all the time and like how
we've changed much has changed and like
it's really amazing
no and i'm eternally grateful to hashem
my lord that i was born a woman in the
age of epidural like i cannot imagine
giving birth in some forlorn castle and
that's best case scenario
uh with like people holding my legs wide
open and a grand maester between my
[ __ ] like absolutely you would get some
milk of the puppy
oh yeah but not not enough to hurt the
baby yeah like oh and what is that
disgusting lesion on the king's back and
what's this disease where the iron is
against his skin like he's bleeding
every time he sits on the throne
uh
i don't he's bleeding every time he sits
on the throne
well he got the lesion from sitting on
the throne and then the next time he was
sitting there he had blood on his pinky
when he kicked out his brother i think
that
he got like he cut himself because he's
sitting on the throne of swords but
there's something about like he has some
sort of blood disorder like almost like
a hemophilia that he could bleed out
that's my theory
oh my theory is like he's not a special
targaryen like it's valerian steel
aren't targaryens supposed to like
you know
you know yeah yeah yeah but he is he had
his hands on the fire i know so that's
what i was thinking too i'm like okay so
he can do the dragon thing yeah
and then at the end there was like this
big secret
did they say the secret or is the secret
that there's winter coming the secret is
that winter is coming uh what a bad
secret because we all know it
yeah it's just like not juicing it's
juicy to them that they have i thought
he was gonna say like uh you're a
baratheon like i thought it was going to
be juicy no like it's a secret to them
they've seen the end of times and it's
up to them
to
turn it's giving bran they need to turn
it around
[Music]
king's landing was looking majorly
forlorn no i thought everything was
looking better like everything's in its
heyday even there at harrenhal in the
beginning like that's that forlorn place
where arya went that one time where she
was like when she was a boy
oh my god i was thinking what is
harrenhal yeah all these places and
people and families like are in their
prime and king's landing like when they
came into like the court of king's
landing where yeah aren't you like
bustling metropolis they're home
yeah yeah yeah yeah i will say the
girlie reneria renee
renee what's her
no you just messed me up i think it's
raining
um stunning literally
when the show opened and she was
touching the granite dragon i thought it
was amelia clark stunning gorgeous girl
gorgeous actress everything of the sword
i went to google her because there's
something about her that's familiar
and then i looked at her catalog and you
know what she's from for five years
what
a place to call home
my favorite show on acorn tv you guys
have to watch the show
but were you also getting like lesbian
love vibes between her and her friends
yes and so obviously her friend's gonna
[ __ ] her dad and also put her like
inheritance into question and it's gonna
be a major betrayal on all fronts and
then vernier is gonna have to push a
[ __ ] down the stairs honestly like
that's what's gonna have to be done
she's not that kind of girl no she's not
power hungry which is why she would make
a great queen yeah and she's humane
which is why she would make a great
queen
yeah i just like was like obsessed with
damon like i'm like yes king oh my god
no he's made me sick
no because he reminds me of
daenerys brother yeah because there is
you know due to all the incest there is
an evil afoot in the targaryen family
and some of them are mad and some of
them are not and as we see here
and what about the king like is he
nefarious i think that he is a
good king he's not a great king he
doesn't have like the person who
anointed him i think was a great king
he's fine he's good i think he could be
easily swayed um
but he's not he's not nefarious no he
made a really bad call obviously in
murdering his wife because he was so
like
wrapped up in his successor and his
legacy but i don't think he is evil i
think he really loved his wife and i
think he's truly heartbroken
yeah me too me too that was low-key sad
looked at us yeah
so good like i loved it yeah cause like
an evil king if you had someone in your
family who was you know calling your
heir for a day like he would have
smote him on the spot yeah yeah yeah
yeah but instead like he just sent him
away but like damon if someone if damon
were king and someone came in and was
like talking trash about damon fed to
the dogs yeah damon's joffrey yeah
but like i still am reserving hope like
maybe he would be a good king like
everyone's just underestimating him i
don't think so but no the the karen king
is very tommen he's good but is he
strong enough
right right he's fine he's fine but fine
is better than you know the mad king
yeah nice to see you know the ancestors
of the starks and the baratheons make
small appearances at the nightingale
yeah everyone
know everyone from like even the dornish
yes handsome man i love him oh he was
cute i love him
i do feel like she's gonna wind up with
her uncle unfortunately i know because
also that guy's uh dad or mom is a
commoner
yeah also i feel like
vernier's friend will be pregnant and in
order to like have a firmer grasp out
succeed firmer grasp on the
title
they will produce an hair as well
i don't know but i also called it all
wrong last night i thought that damon
was gonna die in combat and that the
baby was also gonna die
and no or that the baby was gonna be a
girl and live i thought the baby was
gonna be a girl like [ __ ] you just
killed your wife for nothing and then
damon would be gone and rhaenyra would
be the only air not that it would be a
choice it would just be like it has to
be rainier
and justice for the aunt
always the queen who almost was
the queen who never was or whatever she
would have been good she should do a
podcast on underestimating women
megan should have her on
um so all in all i am so happy to have
this like type of show back in my life i
will be keeping up on a weekly basis um
it was very good i feel like there was
like a lot of drama with what game of
thrones was going to do next there was
like a show
that got cancelled like yeah there was a
lot and this is what we landed on two
houses in the works and
this is when we got
and i love it like i'm loving all the
blonde of hair and i'm loving having
right we're gonna have new huge
celebrities like millie i love
i love the no buddies i love it by the
way i i thought that rainer was supposed
to be nine because they said like nine
years later in the beginning like the
mother was pregnant oh yeah when he
chose the king as his successor
and then it was nine years later and
this girl looks kind of little like
maybe she's just like a 13 year old
playing a nine-year-old she's 22.
oh but i guess the mom was pregnant with
someone else perhaps but yeah yeah maybe
the mom said she was pregnant ten five
times she's 22 in real life
she could how old is venereal disease i
don't know she could be nine
no way
i think she's probably 15 16 shows love
to like give us someone blooming into
adulthood
yeah yeah yeah just like daenerys was
the last thing i wanted to say
i feel like it was about damon because
i'm obsessed oh when he was at the [ __ ]
house um
and i just i love game of thrones for
normalizing the word [ __ ] like
not you know women aren't [ __ ] but
like they were like their title back
then was [ __ ] and i just love saying it
like huh
um when he's at the whorehouse with this
[ __ ]
who's a big fat [ __ ]
um and she's like do you want me to
bring in a girl who has silver hair like
he's obviously obsessed with in like
incest i mean incest is best when you
are a targaryen
and you know what clearly romero's mom
is some sort of targaryen because she
was silver of hair
totally it's giving cousin
yeah
and i actually so i found like a
family tree yeah on twitter last night
that actually gave me a spoiler uh so
don't go and do that
yes how are their spoilers are these
books it shows you who marries who
are these books
uh
i'm not sure but like george so how
would this person know who marries who
oh cause i think in the initial
books they give you all of these family
trees at some point like someone puts it
all together and so um
so don't tell me no no i won't tell you
it's nothing major or anything but i had
to stop looking so
i don't know where emma came from
emma yeah
ama how does he come up with all these
names
no i was okay what is first of all dead
ass i know damon
because it's actually a real name like
damon j
and reneria because she's like the most
important character what the [ __ ] is
everyone what is the king's name
rheumatoid
what is uh
the hand of the king's name otto
hightower
oh good call what is the queen who never
was his name
in that opening scene like nine years
prior they were like my cousin deliria
and my brother veneria with my auntie
reneria
and our daughter shaviria
i was like how am i gonna follow this
show yeah also it's interesting the baby
the air for a day
bombino
balon who we know balon greyjoy
172 years later maybe he had some
targaryen in him if it's a family name
yeah because it wasn't giving veneria it
was like bambino so i was like oh
different family
i was like finally a name i'll be able
to recognize this trial by his name
because it doesn't sound like verneria i
have a question
when the baby came out of the room was
it screaming
was it a baby was fine
for a few hours
then it wasn't
then you heard the baby be like
yeah did you hear that uh
yeah i guess so i thought that the baby
was gonna be like
part baby part dragon who had a baby
like um
like a renesme
no like no not in a good way like in a
in a not good way
well
whatever it was i understood it as like
the baby was born it was healthy it was
a boy and for a second the father was
like oh this was worth murdering my wife
then
it wasn't yeah
i don't even think he felt like it was
worth murdering his wife for that second
i think he was like i got what i wanted
and look it's not even one is it what i
want would i even be happy that's what
rhaenyra said like maybe he'll finally
have experienced a moment's joy having
got him right
i just like i was up all night dreaming
like about
veneria and
liberia i'm obsessed
i can't believe you're so obsessed with
damon he's so scary am i there only one
like no i was right i didn't tweet that
crazy people were like obsessed with the
actor i think like yeah he did a really
good job he's obviously very compelling
and he's the only one who's ready to
[ __ ] [ __ ] up in westeros
yeah and so far he hasn't shown me that
he's like truly evil but we need to know
where those people thieves murders and
rapists i'm sure yeah i guess that's
that's important yeah
i just like him like
need his hair stylist number asap
um so yes we will continue the recaps i
loved it that will be on mondays
yep
and that's all she wrote loved it
there's your tv recaps we're back
there's your tv recaps we're back
uh is that all she wrote that's all she
wrote pencils down everyone
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
podcast anywhere could be fantastic
spotify two season public video
everybody guest box office
let's say we're just just flash
everywhere everybody sorry follow me on
tick tock [ __ ] love you bye